actually there is a fantastic
opportunity for the financial economy to
reconnect with the non financial economy
over the next coming couple of decades
and the reason that I say this is that
if you look back at really how this
whole crisis unfolded it was really due
to this sort of high complexity I think
there was a lack of transparency people
didn't really understand in many cases
what they were buying or being sold but
actually the reality is that you need a
vibrant financial services economy to
work make the world go round and
capitalism can be a good thing all in
good measure so one of the things that
we're emphasizing a lot in the UK
particularly within our own company
Alliance Trust is this aspect of trust
and transparency so what can we do how
can we help
perhaps educate the end consumer as to
what they're really buying and the
perhaps the pitfalls along the way so I
think that actually financial services
companies can offer so many good things
but I think it's also our responsibility
to help end consumers and investors
become more responsible but really by
helping them understand the true
benefits that a successful partnership
or financial services businesses and the
end consumer can truly bring to a
successful and vibrant economy